[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome
to the Quickstart
for Google Cloud
Persistent Disks.
From the VM Instance
page, select your instance
by clicking on its name.
In the VM Instance
Details page, select Edit.
Scroll down to the
Additional Disk section.
And then click Add Item.
Click on the name
and create disk.
In the new dialog that shows
up, enter new-disk for the name
and change the disk type to
Standard persistent disk.
Under Source Type,
select none (blank disk)
and then set the size to 500 GB.
Click Create.
Now back to the VM
Instance Details page,
you will have to scroll
down and then select Save.
We will now confirm
the persistent disk
has been created.
To do that click, SSH to
connect to the new SSH terminal.
It may take some time
to connect sometimes.
But once it connects, let's
type in sudo lsblk and then
the Command sudo mkfs.ext4 -m
0 -F -E lazy_itable_init=0,
lazy_journal_init=0,
discard /dev/sdb.
This will format
the attached disk,
and you will see the inode
tables that are writing.
Now note, this may
take a little bit long.
So we will wait
for it to format.
Almost there.
Once it's done formatting, you
can create a mount directory
with this command sudo mkdir
-p /mnt/disk/mymountdir.
And then mount it with this
command sudo mount -0 discard,
defaults /dev/sdb
/mount/disk/mymountdir.
Finally, change the permissions
on the disk by using sudo chmod
a+w on the mount directory.
Well, congratulations.
You've completed
this Quickstart.